Buenos días y muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros en France 24 para esta
entrevista exclusiva con Efraín alegre
candidato a la presidencia de Paraguay
señora alegré Muchísimas gracias por
conceder esta entrevista a nuestro canal
a usted un placer señor alegre es la
tercera vez que usted se presenta a las
elecciones presidenciales y algunos
sondeos dan ganador al partido Colorado
usted tiene su propia opinión sobre esos
sondeos y me gustaría saber cuál es esta
opinión y también si cree que Paraguay
está preparado para un cambio de rumbo
bueno en primer lugar aclarar que los
sondeos que le dan al partido Colorado
son los que publican el periódico La
Nación de Horacio Carter
del partido Colorado y el jefe del grupo
político de Santiago Peña los demás las
demás encuestas las que no son del
partido Colorado todas las demás
encuestas nos dan a nosotros ganador la
encuesta internacionales que se hacen
las encuestas más serias nos dan a
nosotros ganador Así es que estamos
realmente en primer lugar muy seguros
del triunfo se nota en la calle la gente
este se expresa claramente por el cambio
eso es muy notorio Entonces sí estamos a
pocos días del cambio el pueblo no
solamente está preparado está dispuesto
y resuelto
a producir el cambio el 30 de abril
Santiago Peña es el candidato
precisamente de Horacio cartes que es un
político cuando menos controvertido
sobre el que pesa una orden de
extradición de los Estados Unidos Qué
puede pasar con el país Si gana de forma
digamos indirecta Horacio cartes bueno
no va a ganar en primer lugar
este decir que es controvertido un poco
generoso
es un candidato comprometido Yo te diría
con el crimen organizado transnacional y
no lo digo yo lo dice la investigación
es que hay en el Brasil Las
investigaciones que están en Colombia la
dicen las investigaciones de los Estados
Unidos y lo dicen o lo que acá en el
Paraguay todos los conocemos por eso es
que este es un proyecto que realmente
pone en peligro al país Horacio cartes
es un modelo que ha instalado vinculado
a la corrupción al crimen organizado y
con ese dinero sucio es que controla
fiscalía el poder judicial y sobor
parlamentarios eso no es una
controversia eso es un hecho este
Santiago Peña que es contador de Horacio
cartes es su secretario ellos no le
representan al Paraguay Paraguay es un
pueblo de trabajo de esfuerzo de gente
honesta en caso de ser elegido Cuáles
serían las principales medidas que
piensa adoptar qué necesita Paraguay hoy
Bueno hoy esta mañana he hecho antes que
ibanía pública los cinco primeros
decretos primero la política energética
la nueva política energética que
significa este utilizar nuestros
recursos más abundantes somos campeones
mundiales en energía por habitantes en
el mundo sin embargo nuestra energía
termina en el Brasil termina en
Argentina generando desarrollo en San
Paulo y en otros en otras ciudades de la
Argentina nosotros decimos vamos a
utilizar nuestra energía para nuestro
desarrollo Eso significa generar las
condiciones para la inversión Eso
significa una justicia un poder judicial
pre lo que vamos a trabajar Y eso
significa también que la gente pueda
acceder a una energía que sea más
accesible por eso vamos a bajar el
precio de la tarifa de la energía este
domiciliaria también creemos de que el
desarrollo no solamente la industria
sino del desarrollo del campo acá
tenemos dos tipos de agricultura hasta
la agricultura mecanizada de granos que
se ha desarrollado en una manera
espectacular hay que proteger hay que
respaldar ellos no necesitan mucho
solamente necesitan seguridad para poder
seguir trabajando le vamos a proveer esa
seguridad para que lo sigan haciendo y
está la pequeña agricultura que necesita
un poco más de acompañamiento ellos
también necesitan seguridad para que el
producto de su trabajo tenga precio y
que hoy está este perjudicado por el
contrabando precisamente por el modelo
cartes no cartes y Peña ellos sustentan
alguna declaraciones de Santiago Peña
que dice que el contrabando no es un
delito que el contrabando o sea ellos
defienden el modelo del contrabando de
la informalidad y de la ilegalidad
nosotros decimos no tenemos que cerrar
de tal manera que nosotros podamos
producir lo que necesitan las familias
paraguayas en el sector de la
agricultura familiar que es toda la
producción hortícola imagínense que
tengamos que comprar nosotros este todo
lo que es la producción hortícola
cebolla papa imagínense eso lo podemos
hacer y no lo estamos haciendo porque el
contrabando mata el precio del Pequeño
productor otras medidas que establecimos
urgente es también la medida que refiere
a la salud el hoja gratis le decimos
nosotros es medicamento
esenciales hay medicamentos que son
esenciales para la salud y esos
medicamentos esenciales se garantiza la
gratuidad la gente va a salir con su
medicamento no con la receta como ocurre
hoy que hay veces familias tienen que
decidir si van a comprar el medicamento
o van a comprar alimento a ese nivel y a
ese extremo estamos así que ese es uno
de los proyectos importantes el gratis
también decimos claramente que vamos
este a trabajar en la niñez sin hambre
el Paraguay está invirtiendo mucho
dinero para la meriendas escolar y
terminan del bolsillo de un grupo de
Sinvergüenza Entonces no hay una
política de la merienda no hay no existe
la merienda escolar lo que existe es un
escandaloso robo 115 millones de dólares
por año que es aporte en todos los
ciudadanos eso lo vamos nosotros a hacer
directamente
transfiriendo a las madres esta mujer Es
la que nunca le va a robar al hijo
también vamos a crear una secretaría que
es la secretaría para recuperar y
devolver al pueblo lo es decir hemos
tenido circunstancias lamentables que
hoy el banco interamericano en un
estudio nos dice que en el Paraguay se
roba unos dos mil más de dos mil
millones de dólares que nos están
robando Entonces tenemos una un
compromiso de recuperar y de devolver al
pueblo todo ese dinero que tenemos casos
muy notorios sobre los cuales vamos a
trabajar entonces no solamente ellos
este dejan el gobierno sino que además
tienen que recuperar este lo que se ha
robado Durante este tiempo usted ha
citado la pobreza infantil pero Paraguay
tiene un problema de pobreza estructural
más o menos los datos que he visto un
30% de pobreza y pobreza extrema se
puede resolver este problema o tan solo
mitigar cuál es su opinión no no se
pueden resolver Paraguay es un país que
tiene inmensas oportunidades tiene
riquezas Somos altamente competitivos Lo
importante es saber qué es lo que nos
falta lo que nos falta es seguridad
nos falta justicia nos falta
previsibilidad somos un país Muy
atractivo para la inversión en este
momento este tenemos energía el problema
pasa por la seguridad jurídica por eso
decimos nosotros podemos garantizar la
seguridad jurídica podemos dar seguridad
jurídica para que este país sea
atractivo para que podamos cambiar esa
imagen que lamentablemente Este modelo
de cartes y de Peña ha posicionado ante
el mundo del sicariato de la muerte de
los significativamente corrupto del
crimen organizado tenemos un nivel de
pobreza extrema
pobreza en general rondando el 30 26 27%
Pero tenemos también este una franja de
un sector digamos que todavía es
informal Entonces es vulnerable Entonces
estamos hablando de un ciento un poco
más de un 50% de la población que es
vulnerable ellos necesitan Un gobierno
que dé seguridad y estabilidad A
diferencia de hace cinco años usted se
presenta con una mujer como
vicepresidenta Cuál es la importancia en
el Paraguay contemporáneo de tener una
mujer en su lista Bueno es muy fuerte no
solamente
en la chapa no soledad Núñez y desierto
es este están la chapa una mujer Este
joven muy dinámica muy capaz con una
trayectoria impecable Este pero Nosotros
hemos hecho historia hemos resuelto en
primer lugar la paridad en las
candidaturas plurinominales
y hemos comprometidos estamos
comprometiendo el gabinete
que vamos a inaugurar el 15 de agosto va
a ser un gabinete donde por lo menos el
50%
serán ministras mujeres
y cuál es su posición sobre el aborto
Paraguay arrastra un problema
estructural de embarazos indeseados y
precoces entre niñas y adolescentes de
10 a 19 años hay varios informes de la
ONU que apuntan a que ese es un problema
la familia tendrá una presencia directa
en la educación de sus hijos en primer
lugar en segundo lugar los otros creemos
por la vida nosotros no estamos en
ninguna despenalización del aborto ni a
ninguna cuestión es que este signifiquen
cuestiones que van en primer lugar en
contra nuestras disposiciones
constitucionales esos son más bien
planteamientos que se hacen con
propósito de generar confusión en un
proceso electoral nuestras
constituciones que
este es nuestra ley madre están
resueltos estos problemas no hay nada
que discutir en el caso de que usted
llegue al gobierno Cómo asegurar la
gobernabilidad porque usted se va a
encontrar con un congreso con muchos
colorados no Entonces todos tenemos en
la cabeza quién le dio esa información
En qué se funda eso no es cierto
nosotros todas nuestras proyecciones
señalan que vamos a tener por lo menos
una cámara de senadores con una mayoría
Clara de la posición y creemos que
también en diputado no o sea son
especulaciones que se hacen Este no nos
preocupa absolutamente
nosotros entendemos claramente que la
democracia no se resuelve entre el
presidente y el congreso si creemos que
ahí está la democracia estaremos muy
equivocados nosotros creemos en una
democracia con una participación activa
de la ciudadanía Qué tipo de país va a
heredar en casa de ganar
parece que Paraguay va a tener un
crecimiento económico por encima de la
media de la región Pero cuál es la
herencia de Mario abdo en caso de que
usted gane y tenga que gerenciar este
país bueno nosotros vamos a recibimos un
país con una institucionalidad
democrática muy frágil no tenemos una ma
croeconomía relativamente equilibrada
los últimos años Lamentablemente entre
cartel y hablo han endeudado un poco más
de lo que se recomienda de todas maneras
nuestros este número son mucho mejor que
todo el resto de la región Así es que
tenemos esas oportunidades nos falta
seguridad jurídica institucionalidad
tenemos que desalojar esta mafia este
dinero sucio
que nos ha traído el modelo cartista que
ha metido plata en la fiscalía
que ha metido dinero en el poder
judicial y ha sobornado se ha dedicado a
sobornar parlamentario Entonces ese
dinero sucio Ese es nuestro enemigo
vamos a crecer mucho más que los números
que hoy anuncian a partir de poder
ofrecer seguridad jurídica seguridad
jurídica es lo que nos falta para tener
grado de inversión
y el grado de inversión significa que
podamos crecer de 300 millones de
dólares de inversión que estamos
recibiendo por año en este momento a
2000 a 2500 o a 3000 imagínense lo que
eso impacta en una economía como la
Nuestra Señora alegre Muchísimas gracias
por esta entrevista en exclusiva y
gracias a ustedes por acompañarnos hasta
aquí les invitamos a que sigan nuestra
programación en France 24 y en France
24.com